la era de barack obama uno de los
presidentes sin duda más mediáticos y
populares de la historia de los eeuu ha
llegado a su fin si tuviésemos que
definir a obama bien podríamos decir que
ha sido una brillante estrella a cuyo
lado muchos de los grandes nombres de
hollywood quedarían eclipsado
amigos de visual político no solo gana
la casa blanca sino que con la promesa
de contribuir a construir un mundo mejor
y a regenerar la forma hacer política se
hizo con las esperanzas de cientos de
millones de personas dentro y fuera de
los eeuu como es normal con el paso de
los años su brillo ha perdido fuerza y
la controversia se puede decir ganó a la
percepción casi mesiánica con la que
llegó al poder
[Música]
porque amigos obama más que un
presidente parecía el salvador de la
humanidad pues bien si en un vídeo
anterior repasamos su política
internacional en este vídeo queremos
fijarnos en la herencia que le deja su
sucesor en el despacho oval
donald trump
si algo está claro es que barack obama
llegó al poder en uno de los momentos
más difíciles que un político se puede
imaginar en medio de una época que
parecía incluso el propio armageddon en
aquel entonces a finales de 2008 y
principios de 2009 cada mes 800.000
estadounidenses perdían su trabajo las
bolsas se desplomaban el sistema
financiero parecía fuera de control en
caída libre y los periódicos
prácticamente abrían cada día con la
quiebra de algún gran grupo empresarial
hoy 8 años después las cosas son
bastante distintas y obama es por
supuesto el primero en recordarlo la
verdad es que si tuvieras que elegir un
momento de la historia para estar vivo
escogería esté aquí mismo en américa
ahora mismo se mira como se mida este
país es mejor y el mundo es mejor de lo
que lo era hace 50 38 años sin embargo
esta es una imagen que puede
sorprendernos si tenemos en cuenta que
cuando se le pregunta a los ciudadanos
de eeuu si su país estaba mejor o peor
que hace 10 años los estadounidenses
parecen confusos indeciso
y una gran mayoría de ellos más de dos
terceras partes afirman que el país
sigue un rumbo equivocado una postura
claro que resulta menos extraña si
tenemos en cuenta el caldo de cultivo
generado durante la última campaña por
algunos medios de comunicación y
especialmente algunos políticos es el
caso desde luego de donald trump cuyo
discurso político describía a eeuu como
un país en crisis decadente y casi como
un estado fallido del que llegó a decir
que se estaba convirtiendo ni más ni
menos que en un país del tercer mundo
tal y como dijo en el washington post
pero que éramos un país muy poderoso muy
rico y ahora somos un país pobre no sé
si el tercer mundo pero una cosa es
cierta cuando visitas eeuu te das cuenta
que las infraestructuras las carreteras
del país están que se caen a pedazos
bien llegados a este punto la pregunta
es clara quién de los dos tiene razón o
al menos quién se aproxima más a la
verdad pues bien para contestar a esta
pregunta vamos a tratar de hacer una
fotografía de la herencia que deja
barack obama de los principales
indicadores económicos de eeuu
éxitos de la administración obama nunca
antes en la historia de eeuu había
habido tantos empleos como hoy en día
algo más de 152 millones de personas
trabajan en la economía norteamericana
de tal forma que durante la presidencia
de barack obama se han creado más de 11
millones de nuevos puestos de trabajo en
el sector privado 15 si contamos desde
que comenzó la recuperación ojo porque
son muchos empleos por ejemplo en el
mismo periodo de tiempo la eurozona ha
destruido empleo de tal forma que aún
hoy la zona euro tiene menos
trabajadores que en 2008 aquí podéis ver
la diferente evolución de ambos
territorios
[Música]
hoy la tasa de desempleo en eeuu están
atentos en torno al 45 por ciento en
nuestra mano y no se trata sólo de la
cifra bruta de empleo en términos reales
los ingresos medios por trabajador se
encuentran ya en máximos históricos y
desde 2012 los salarios han aumentado
más de un 5 por ciento en términos
reales es decir una vez descontada ya la
inflación los estadounidenses tienen hoy
más trabajo y de media mejores salarios
que nunca antes en la historia
esto sí que parece una recuperación lo
mismo deberían tomar boca en españa' y
claro como resultado de todo este
proceso el porcentaje de estadounidenses
considerados como pobres cayó a su nivel
mínimo en 8 años y ojo la reducción de
la pobreza relativa ha sido generalizada
se ha producido en todos los estados y
en todos los grupos de edad
cuando obama llegó a la casa blanca en
2009 la tasa de pobreza era del 14,5 por
ciento el dato más reciente de la
oficina del censo americano muestra que
la cifra se ha reducido hasta el 13,7
por ciento el año pasado desde sus
niveles más bajos como consecuencia de
la crisis los precios de la vivienda ya
están repuntando y el s p500 el índice
que mide la actividad de los mercados de
valores de eeuu también hoy se
encuentran máximos históricos todo esto
ha hecho que el patrimonio de las
familias su riqueza se haya disparado
bajo la presidencia de obama más de un
20 por ciento limpio de inflación hay
quien incluso ya dice que estamos a las
puertas de una nueva época de años locos
la asociación de agentes de bienes
raíces indicó que el inventario subió en
murió un 5,6 por ciento y llegó a 2
millones 280 mil casas
y más la producción industrial se ha
recuperado y está casi en máximos
históricos el país es menos dependiente
del petróleo extranjero de lo que lo ha
sido en las tres últimas décadas las
exportaciones crecen con fuerza y los
beneficios empresariales se han más que
doblado hace 40 años el mercado
productor de petróleo era liderado por
países como arabia saudita y rusia hoy
la historia ha cambiado gracias a la
tecnología y eeuu ocupa ese lugar más
empleos más salarios más riqueza barack
obama tomó un barco que hacía agua y hoy
ocho años después deja como legado una
sólida recuperación que ha llevado a la
economía estadounidense a cifras récord
y de hecho su pib y real tierra 2016 en
un nivel un 12% superior al máximo
alcanzado antes de la crisis hoy la
economía estadounidense es más grande
que nunca no es extraño que bajo este
escenario la reserva federal comienza a
poner orden en su política monetaria y
haya comenzado ya a subir los tipos de
interés nuestras proyecciones elevan los
tipos de interés al 1 4% para finales
del año que viene al 2,1 por ciento para
finales de 2018 y al 2 9% para finales
2019 y si las cosas se siguen haciendo
bien eeuu tiene un futuro prometedor por
cierto para todos los que tengan la
tentación de creer que obama ha
expandido el gasto público siento
defraudados porque lo cierto es que en
términos de pib lo ha reducido
sustancialmente algo muy distinto a lo
que como veis ha hecho por ejemplo
españa
[Música]
ahora bien no todo son luces los
críticos de obama ponen sobre la mesa
sombras que también nosotros compartimos
las sombras económicas de la era obama
con seguridad la mayor crítica que
recibe obama ha sido la referente a su
incapacidad para controlar las cuentas
públicas es verdad que desde 2009 el
déficit público se ha reducido
sustancialmente en dos terceras partes
pero también lo es que continúa siendo
bastante abultado y que incluso la
previsión es que empeore en los próximos
años si no se llevan a cabo importantes
recortes del gasto nuestra proyección
asumiendo una continuación en las
políticas es que el déficit supere el
billón de dólares en 2020 ligeramente
por debajo del 5% del pib está por
estimación puede que explique por qué
obama apenas se refiere al presupuesto
federal oa la deuda pública cuando
recalca sus logros y es que atentos a
esta realidad porque es impresionante
durante los 8 años de presidencia de
obama el déficit acumulado del gobierno
general ha sido de 73 millones de
dólares ojo a este dato porque implica
que en tan sólo dos mandatos de obama la
deuda pública ha aumentado en un importe
que es más del doble que toda la deuda
holanda desde la independencia del país
es decir hubo más endeudado más que
todos los presidentes de la historia de
eeuu
juntos
impresionante o por ejemplo otra forma
de verlo este incremento de la deuda
equivale a todo el gasto militar de
rusia durante los próximos 100 años
y esto nos parece muchísimo pero no
podemos olvidar que en españa hemos
consumido más recursos relativos y hoy
tenemos más déficit más deuda menos
trabajo y menos salarios que antes de la
crisis así que algo bien habrá hecho
obama chip nuevo toro sí mismo corriente
pues porque confío en mí de todas formas
no son pocos los economistas que
critican que con todos los estímulos
aplicados tanto por los diferentes
gobiernos como por la reserva federal y
además en el marco de una política de
tipos cero la recuperación no ha sido
tan vigorosa los partidarios de obama
responden que esto se debe
fundamentalmente a que es muy difícil
estimar la producción de la nueva
industria digital ya que la demografía
está envejeciendo por otra parte a pesar
de las cifras récord de empleo son
muchos los que apuntan que la creación
de empleo aún no está siendo lo
suficientemente fuerte como para hacer
frente a toda la demanda potencial
existente lo que achacan a las numerosas
regulaciones introducidas por el
presidente de hecho tanto en el índice
doing bussiness como en el índice de
libertad económica y eeuu ha perdido
varios puestos desde la llegada al poder
de obama el presidente de eeuu barak
obama ordena al departamento de trabajo
o que impulse nuevas normas para evitar
conflictos de intereses entre las
corredurías the wall street' que
asesoran a clientes sobre sus
inversiones vinculadas a pensiones y la
última critica a pesar de la buena
marcha de las cosas aún hay 43 millones
de personas consideradas pobres en eeuu
y desde luego eso de sáfina en la
interpretación del primer presidente
afroamericano de la historia de este
país en fin por la economía y por las
reformas que ha implantado más allá de
ella como veíamos en política exterior
personalmente creo que la valoración que
se pueda hacer de obama es bastante
positiva y a pesar de las sombras que
hay nadie puede tener ninguna duda en
eeuu es un país mejor hoy que hace 50 30
e incluso 8 años bueno tú qué opinas
sobre obama te ha parecido un buen
presidente o eres de los que creen que
han cumplido las expectativas fácil
desde luego no lo ha tenido espero que
te haya gustado este vídeo si ha sido
así no dudes en darle al like i em
suscribirte al canal si aún no lo has
hecho lo puedes hacer ahora gratis
pulsando en este botón un saludo y hasta
la próxima amigos
creemos no es lógico no
[Aplausos]